hey guys dr berg here in this short
video we're going to show you two
different simple home tests that you can
do for adrenal fatigue and all you need
is a flashlight okay so number one the
holding your breath test now one good
indication of adrenal fatigue is the
ability to hold your breath for long
periods of time if you can't
you probably have an adrenal issue
because the oxygen in your lungs is
connected to
the adrenals and so
if
you have really good adrenals you can
hold your breath for like a minute or
longer there's a guy who came in my
office who is 80 years old okay he had
the best adrenals i've ever seen in my
life he can heal real fast and i have a
machine that measures the adrenals and
he had a perfect score so i asked him
what did he do
his whole life
well he was he took
first place in the olympics when he was
like 20 years old
for water polo
and he was able to hold his breath for
at least three to four minutes so he can
keep he can actually hold his breath now
for three minutes underneath the water
so his adrenals are really tough you
have adrenal case they're huffing and
puffing upstairs they run out of air
real quick they cannot hold their breath
so that's the first test okay
okay so number two is the iris test now
what is the iris the iris is kind of
like the aperture of the eye now what is
an aperture aperture is just a opening
in the camera that allows the light to
go in at a certain level so this is the
same thing so if there's a real bright
light
the
iris contracts and constricts
the amount of light going into the eye
because it might be too harmful if it's
dark out it actually is very very open
okay so it controls the light so if i'm
going to shine a light into the eye
okay like this
this thing normally should contract
now what's controlling that is something
called the autonomic nervous system or
the sympathetic nervous system
what is that that's the nervous system
that is intimately involved with flight
or fight in the adrenal so the adrenals
control that
part of the other parts of the body
control it but the adrenal gland is also
involved so if there's a weakness with
the adrenal and you shine a light into
the eye
what will happen it'll contract it'll
constrict but it will not maintain that
constriction so it might kind of hold it
for about five seconds or ten seconds
and it starts going
[Music]
it actually fluctuates it kind of comes
open and close
because it cannot hold that constriction
so
if you can hold that constriction and
keep this thing constricted for like at
least a minute then your adrenals are
good so it's a real simple test so in
this next part i'll show you exactly i
do a little demo of how to do it okay
guys the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to shine a light into the
eye
and if you see the little black part in
the center that's the pupil okay that's
the hole right into the eye and then the
outer part which is kind of the color
part that's called the iris that's
contracting constricting and relaxing so
when that contracts
it makes the pupil the little center
part gets smaller
or larger depending on what's happening
okay so when you shine light in there
normally the iris the outer part is
supposed to contract and hold that
position for at least one to two minutes
so if
that contraction
cannot occur
that means the adrenal glands are weak
and you'll start seeing the
the pupil get bigger and smaller like a
wave like it will not be able to
maintain a very
tight contraction
okay
so you can just do this in the mirror
look into the mirror shine the light
into the eye the small little pupil
should get smaller and maintain
that smallness by keeping the light held
steady if it starts to get weak and
start to open up which a lot of times it
will within about i don't know 10 to 15
seconds then we know the adrenals are
weak because the entire nervous system
that controls that is weak okay guys so
now that you have a way to figure out
your adrenals and the question is what
do you do about it there's a great
little kit that i have to help the
adrenal glands so i put the link below
check it out if you want some help
thanks for watching